let's talk about immigration a little
bit the current presidents disgusting
policy towards immigration is exceeded
really only by his personal hypocrisy
towards immigrants we've known for a
long time that many of the companies
that Donald Trump hired to build his
buildings around the world and
particularly in New York employed
undocumented immigrants but there was
this sort of layer separating them from
Donald Trump Trump hired a contractor
the contractor hired undocumented
immigrants that's not Trump but that is
now been blown wide open by the New York
Times report which explains that Donald
Trump had specific names specific
undocumented immigrants that were
working at minimum at his New Jersey
Golf Club the report talks about
Victoria Morales who made Donald Trump's
bed and cleaned his toilet and dusted
off those bogus golf trophies he got
because people let him win all at his
Golf Club in New Jersey she is an
undocumented immigrant and I could tell
you the full story of her life in detail
how she came to the u.s. from Guatemala
how Donald Trump hired her in 2013 how
she isn't the only person at Donald
Trump's New Jersey night New Jersey Golf
Club who's undocumented but you probably
already understand the story here
whether it's Victoria Morales or Sandra
Diaz or whoever else
Trump's business employed undocumented
immigrants so there are a few issues
here that we should be talking about
first is that this could be another
Trump crime companies aren't that often
prosecuted for this but 8 USC subsection
1324 says that any person who during a
12-month period knowingly hires for
employment at least 10 individuals with
actual knowledge that the individuals
are aliens shall be fined under Title 18
or imprisoned for not more than five
years or both now of course we would
need to know the total number of
undocumented immigrants who were working
for Trump and then we would get into
whether Trump knowingly had these
individuals working for him it would be
difficult to prove they complete
ignorance but even if they avoid guilt
by the led
the law Donald Trump's own companies
violated the spirit of the law so then
we get to the real story which is Donald
Trump's hypocrisy Trump who says that
Mexicans are rapists shut down Muslim
immigration militarized the border and
chain migration and birthright
citizenship that same politician has
number one employed undocumented
immigrants number two has a wife who was
working in the United States illegally
has a wife whose parents became citizens
of the United States via chain migration
provided a place his resort in Florida
for Russian women to come and have
babies who then become citizens via the
same birthright citizenship that he
claims to oppose I think he sort of got
the picture right so the hypocrisy is
not new the fact that Trump is want care
also isn't new the important point is we
need to more seriously go after
companies who employ undocumented
immigrants if this is our policy if this
is the law then it can't just be that we
deport the undocumented people when
they're caught the companies that hire
them must be seriously punished but it's
not going to happen because the people
at the top don't really want that and I
hope Pat that I'm making this really
clear the companies want scared
vulnerable immigrants who can be
exploited at low wages who won't say
anything because they're worried about
being caught and getting deported the
companies are the ones you should be mad
at not the immigrants and this has been
one of the amazing victories of the
corporate apparatus Pat which is they've
managed to make it so that Americans are
mad at immigrants for quote taking their
jobs instead of being mad at the
companies that lobbied for the situation
where they can save money by hiring
those undocumented immigrants that's
absolutely right and even for someone
like Trump who's taken such a
comprehensive look at immigration and
really made it a pinnacle of his policy
agenda you know he's talked about
building a wall
between the US and Mexico he's talked
about ending birthright citizenship
family separation ramping up
deportations but he stays silent on this
one and it's pretty obvious because that
would directly affect him and his
buddies his his business interests are
directly opposite what we know is the
quickest way to end undocumented
immigration in terms of a way to find
jobs buckle down on businesses who
employ undocumented immigrants big fines
for each undocumented immigrant that a
business employs period and yeah things
will cost more this is why the focus is
on the immigrants and not on the
companies because the companies win by
employing cheap undocumented labor and
in a way Americans are also winning if
indeed you believe that that's holding
down the cost of goods and services so
instead the focus is on let's deport the
bad people who are coming here to work
who of course drive up profit margins
for corporations and keep products
cheaper for Americans one of the day's
sponsors is privacy dot-com slash Pakman
which is a free service that I myself
use really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a
service like this for example you can
sign up for as many free trials as you
want then just delete the virtual credit
card you used and never worry about
getting charged for it it protects you
from getting hacked it protects you when
companies are hacked which happens all
the time it is all completely free all
you have to do is click the link under
this video to get started and for a
limited time there giving everyone in
our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link